good morning belief nation today's
message is just to you over to you ed
sheeran yeah I guess my advice for young
performance is just just do you like
there's seven billion people in this
world and there was no one like you and
there's no one he's gonna write
someone's like you know and he's gonna
sing like you as long as you keep it
exactly yourself I mean imitate people
to a point to get your influence and
kind of help you write songs and help
you learn guitar and help you sing but
once you've found your voice just do
that and stick with it and even if it
sounds like it's older than people are
telling you it won't work just stick
with it and eventually it will because
there's seven billion people in the
world there's bound to be one person
that likes your music so what do you
think okay so just to you for me it's
like super important like a lot of
people kind of do everything in their
day modeled after someone else so
they're trying to be like that celebrity
or they're trying to be that guy that
they see
like at school everyday basically so
you're kind of living your life for
someone else and you're kind of
restricting your natural tendencies of
the person your natural behaviors as a
person and I think when people start
doing that you kind of put a hold on or
put a lid on your talents like your
natural talents as a person which makes
you unique and the people like if you
look at celebrities or people who are
making it big and famous there usually
they have something about them that's
unique to that person so not doing you
prevents you from achieving I guess your
potential as a person I like that man I
was gonna go in a totally different way
but I like that
so I'll riff off of that and I think a
lot of people you have to be to decide
if you want to live your version of your
life or someone else's version of your
life and we all have these expectations
put on us by our parents our family our
friends that you have to live this life
and that kind of keeps keeps you in your
box in your bubble and the way to break
out is to decide that I'm gonna live my
version of my life and when you can make
that mental leap then greatness can
happen so the question of the day today
is what is doing you mean to you well
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an spresso okay
this prey so keep me going